rich why do you think
why do you think women are going to be
single uh and childless
at least half let's just say within the
next nine years
well to add to what aaron's already
listed there which i
co-signed um
top-shelf men are starting to avoid
insufferable women
you know they're starting to realize
that the juice ain't worth the squeeze
um it's not worth exposing themselves
and their
wealth to huge amounts of risk
to hashtag boss girls that are you know
going to make their life difficult
after they've been chasing excellence
all day long they come home and you know
get brow beaten sort of thing
um there's not a lot of uh incentive
anymore to have in
families and children i mean if you look
at this you know the
stats and the way that things have
changed in the fabric of uh
you know the nuclear families changed
over the uh century
so um that leaves a lot of you know
women out to pasture to climb the
corporate ladder
you know collect cats and box wine
subscriptions and um
you know go globalism feminism and all
the other isms and
big daddy states you know their favorite
lover now
george do you have any thing to add to
that yeah i mean if you go through
and do the math on uh
what most women's expectations are what
their
um i don't want to say objectives but i
guess for lack of a better word we'll
say
objectives in trying to find a long-term
relationship or a husband
you know they'll list all of these
things well the guy's got to be straight
okay he's got to be between this age
group he'd uh ideally he'd make this
amount of money he's got to be
a leader of men he's got to pursue
excellence he has to do all these things
you know
and um then you go through and say okay
well
let's just assume that you live in a
town of a million people
and then you go through and you say okay
well how many men are there in this
million people okay there's 500
000. well how many fall into this age
group okay well now maybe you've got
uh 20 000 and how many of those guys are
are you know fit all these other
categories what it boils down to is like
five or six
you know and that's what all and that's
what all the gals
want because again it goes back to
hypergamy when they're
increasing their socioeconomic level
you know and the guys aren't doing it at
the same pace
then there's going to be fewer and fewer
and fewer options
that fit their checklist of
what they're looking for and uh it just
it is what it is
and it's uh you know women can say
that's right wrong guys can get pissed
off about it
but um i think that the powerful message
for guys and women is that if guys just
go out
and do what rich talks about you know it
it's it's
if you just pursue excellence and you do
not pursue women
uh you're gonna have the best of both
worlds and
the women whatever woman you choose to
be a part of your life
is going to have a much much much better
experience and the relationship overall
is going to be much better because at
the end of the day you guys know as well
as i do that women
they say they can say whatever but they
they want a guy that's you know not an
[ __ ] or not a prick or anything like
that but a guy that can really take
charge
and someone that isn't afraid to make a
decision and someone that is decisive
someone that's a leader of men and uh
someone that has a high degree of
competency
and ambition you know this is what
really
uh women respect in men and i think that
once
um you know a lot of guys fall into the
trap
they get married and they think that
they don't have to worry about it
anymore
because it's till death do us part so i
don't have to go to the gym i don't have
to continue
to grow my business i don't have to
continue to you know achieve 100 of my
god-given potential and then once the
the the gal sees that you know
subconsciously that's the biggest turn
off
ever and um you know you guys know where
it goes from there so my whole point
with the
layering over economics is just to point
out that i think this trend will
continue
and although jp morgan might have been
looking at it from standpoint of
consumption
like consumer goods what are they going
to consume more i would look at it from
a standpoint
of demographics having a real population
problem and in a world and in an economy
where you always have to continue to
create more debt
and more dollars if you have a
decreasing population
that's a big problem and then what
happens is the government steps in
and tries to counter uh act that with
we'll call it printing money for lack of
a better term and then you have more
money
being created but you have fewer goods
and services and at the end of the day
the wealth
of the economy is a measurement of the
goods and services it can produce
efficiently you know i use the example
of time if you're on a deserted island
and you had a billion dollars in a chest
and would you be rich or poor you'd be
poor because there's nothing to buy
so the the amount of dollars in the
system doesn't matter
and this takes us to ubi you know i
think that the
the part of the problem here the welfare
state if you go back because it's
allowed women to make decisions that
they otherwise wouldn't make
and again you can say that's good but
you got to look at the cost
benefit analysis it's not just the
benefit
there's also a cost involved in any
decision
where you're dealing with economics
which is really defined by
the allocation of scarce resources with
alternative uses
and so i i think that it it's it's more
than just
you know buying certain things and not
buying other things because women are
more control
over the majority of money being spent i
think it's the the fact that this
produces an environment
where the uh the free market isn't
working at full
capacity because so many men have been
eliminated
out of the system and then you go and
combine that with the fact that
most of these young boys you know that
are the future entrepreneurs as well as
the women but you know the guys really
getting out there and hustling and
driving
the economy forward it's always that top
one percent of producers
you know i think rich knows that well
and now we're in an environment because
of the welfare state
where the majority of those young men
who are extremely talented
and the young women but i think this
inversely affects men more
they're raised in a single family or
single
mother household and then when they go
to school 95 percent of the teachers are
female
so then they grow up in that environment
and i think that
you know what does that do to society at
large as far as our ability
to start businesses to take risk to
to be leaders to go out there and solve
problems
to be ambitious to to create goods and
services and compete at a global level
i think it decreases our ability to do
that and the government
fills the gap with money printing which
uh most likely creates consumer price
inflation
which i'll save for later in the
discussion because that
the viewers right now can do to actually
protect themselves and maybe
uh build wealth and thrive in kind of
this crazy environment that we're moving
into
yeah just like if i just top up and what
george was saying there i just want to
add this because amelia
this is probably the first time in
history
ever where we essentially have a
gigafactory that makes betas
on such a large level yeah right
like there's a lot of men today that
aren't even involved with women period
right right yeah i was gonna say it's
like there's
it's not just like guys getting into a
marriage and then sort of giving up it's
guys giving up
on marriage all together nice giving up
on women and then
giving up on women not even in marriage
yeah once the guy
the conscience of subconsciously gives
up hope
that they can pass on their dna that's a
that's not
that's a powder keg right would you can
i destroy something
yeah go ahead just hope aaron i'm gonna
destroy so if there was any remaining
uh but what george was saying his
primary concern is that obviously humans
are the source of all economic
production as
our population shrinks it has bad
tidings for the future economy but
to put some numbers on this is what i
put together this is really just an
actuarial study
and this is the best statistics i could
come up with um
to show you how little demand there is
on the side of women interested in the
average guy
and that's what this i had to assume a
guy a stereotype just your average guy
of five and
assumptions and all that made only 2.9
of women are really interested in your
average guy
right they are more interested in
careers the other things that we've
talked about also
sexual attraction as well if you throw
that in there as well
and you have to think about what just a
small
eye of a needle that puts the future of
this particular population through like
only less than five percent of the women
out there are willing to
uh commit get with former families with
the average guy and george is right
that's going to have a horrific effect
on the future economic production of the
united states or let alone any other
country with very low birth rates
if you think birth rates are low now
just wait i think it's
the the first derivative is going to
accelerate
uh marriage rates procreation rates
fertility rates
and things like that but it's already
bad now for girls between
18 and 35 and going forward i can't
imagine being uh
much better but there is very little
demand
uh for the average guy out there and
then i don't know there's this hang on
let me see i got it here somewhere
social media exacerbates that problem
right right you guys talking about many
times
but but in order to in order to even be
in the procreation game you
maybe you should read this book i don't
know maybe you want to read that book
but you really gotta be in a top
elite class uh so yeah this is
definitely throwing a a monkey into the
reproductivity uh a monkey wrench in the
reproductivity machine and and
by association by consequence the
economy in the future
yeah yeah it's i mean the solution if
you're to able just to wave a magic wand
is for women's standards to
to lower or for men to get that much
better and i i don't see
either of those happening right now
especially
on an evolutionary scale women are not
going to give that up
that's simply like women look for
quality they don't look like men are
looking for qual
quantity women look for quality yeah
and so when that quality is paired with
economic attractiveness like remember
those i was as far back as like 2018
i was doing uh shows with pat campbell
back then we were talking about the uh
the research findings i guess that um
that showed that you know women
were not finding guys economically
attractive and that's actually one of
the things that i've got on here is
is um is the fact that um
that the idea of like say love or family
formation
or marriages for you know however you
want to you want to pair this up
um when women are making more money than
men
that is something that is like on an
evolutionary level on an innate level
and an instinctual level it's hard for
women to accept that
regardless of i mean unless the guy has
something that is really
uh like a 10-inch personality and is
really yoked and really
he like satisfies that kind of alpha
seed side of hypergamy
there's going to be problems um so when
women get
are in the workforce and uh even if a
couple starts out making exactly the
same amount of money that woman gets a a
bonus but she gets a raise or she gets a
promotion of some sort
that is a precipitator of a divorce
right there
and because women are looking for a guy
who makes more money than them who has
higher value than them and that higher
value takes the form of a lot of
different things and primarily today
in a transactional nature it's it's it's
money it's economics
and i think that's probably one of the
reasons why women are going to
be more lonely and and without without
children and without marriage and i
think that right now we're kind of
looking
at a way of justifying that because we
know it's coming down the road
you